good morning Hank it's Wednesday in your
video on Monday you talked about lots of
ways I can keep from linguistically
embarrassing myself and I appreciate
that but I want to add one small little
thing as you pointed out the word effect
can be used either as a noun or a verb
but I would like to give you some advice
when you want to use effect as a verb
don't ever no matter what so I guess you
know I read books for a living those
books on occasion win awards they are
translated into many languages and they
are often nicely reviewed around the
world I mean the New York Times Book
Review once called one of my books
almost miraculous to which I say almost
so I think I tell you this not to brag
or to encourage nerdfighters to buy my
books although there are links to do so
in the doobly-doo but only to point out
that being a professional person of
letters such as myself does not mean
that you will not on occasion make
hideous grammatical mistakes such as the
double negative in that sentence crap
double negatives right so three years
ago the Yeti and I moved from New York
City to Indianapolis and we had a lot
more space in Indianapolis which meant
that we had to buy a lot of furniture so
one day a couple months after we moved
Indianapolis we're in a furniture store
and I say to Sara do you think we need a
Chester drawers and she says do I think
we need a what a Chester drawers hey
what are drawers a Chester drawer Sarah
do you think we need a Chester drawers
and she looks over at me the man she is
contractually obligated to spend the
rest of her life with and says well we
might need a chest of drawers Oh chest
of drawers not Chester drawers also I
was probably about 25 years old when I
realized that the orders I was eating at
various functions were the exact same
thing as the do for us I was
reading about in books and every time I
would read do furs in a book I
would think that doesn't sound like a
very sophisticated thing to be doing
that sounds like something you order at
a brothel hold on I got about Willian
hey Willy treat come on get the treat
get the treat good news and bad news
Willard good news you're inside bad news
the treat is a lot Hank while we're on
the topic I just want to mention who and
that who describes a person that
describes everything other than a person
I mentioned this because one of my
favorite bands is called the Avot
brothers or possibly the event brothers
are possibly the avett brothers facing
the song that I really love that I
really love not who I really love but
the lyrics infuriate me because at one
point they saying I want to have
friends that I can trust friends you can
trust like what like a tomato plant or a
Super Nintendo or a tennis racket
because if you mean a person it's who
not that but let me just acknowledge
that the job of grammar and
pronunciation is to make language as
clear and efficient and transparent as
possible right but if we're all
constantly correcting each other's
grammars and being really snotty about
it then people stop talking because they
start to be petrified that they'll make
some kind of terrible grammatical error
and that's precisely the opposite of
what grammar is supposed to do which is
to facilitate clear communication so I
propose that in comments today instead
of recounting all of the times that we
mix up the words orgasm and organism in
biology class which happened a lot
according to the comments from your
Monday video we all come together and
nonce Nottoli ask and answer grammatical
and pronunciation questions we've always
had for instance as you've probably
noticed I don't know how to pronounce
the avid brothers or avett brothers or a
vet bro fares I also despite working
with words for a living do not have an
a-number-one handle on the difference
between lie and lay so what don't you
understand and if you know the answers
share them nonce naughtily Hank I'm on
my way to walk pack of Wisconsin where
I'll be speaking on Friday and Saturday
more info in the doobly-doo but Edgar
we'll see you on Friday
except not really because his eyes are
closed